so thank you very much for opportunity
to talk to this conference
and uh
today i would like to present uh some
interesting observations and pitfalls of
model ovulation first of all just try to
think about when i say that my forecast
is better than your focus what do you
think i did yeah
so might be you think i calculated one
metric with your focus and my focus
might be i call it as a set of metrics
might be i clustered my data in
different subsets different categories
and calculated metrics on these
categories maybe i calculate return of
investment on
different forecasts so i might be these
different things
but what is important
do you really know if
this methodology leads to selecting
better forecasts
we used to do
repetitive things or the same in the
same way based on maybe our experience
maybe based on our experience other
experience or maybe based on some just
workflows that everybody does yeah
so let's try to a bit rethink what we
do and actually what the effect of this
and what actually biases
uh it can lead to
uh
so first of all let's
look a bit of the history of focused
evaluation and
uh what is traditionally done
first of all traditional focus is quite
often quite simple uh statistical
algorithms some moving average
uh
versus uh
more than machine learning focus is
complex machine learning algorithms okay
obvious
also traditional forecasting was done
mostly done for some um
univariate time series where you just
use your time series and do some
forecasting while
modern forecasting is usually using
multiple influencing variables effects
for example for demand forecasting it
will be where the price is
cannibalization a lot of stun
a lot of stuff
so
on top of this we have that uh
traditional forecasting was forecasting
for on quite aggregated level because if
you use time series you need really a
lot of
kind of data to run a simple algorithm
on quite aggregated level to pick up for
example seasonality or whatever yeah
while machine learning forecasting can
go quite a very granular prediction
level and predicting product demands on
really product location hour level
and so on so
now taking this in mind what's actually
evolating traditional forecast yeah
quite often it's one maybe two metrics
in sales forecasting is actually often a
mean absolute percentage error according
to
not so old studies
so
also quite often what we mean it means
that there are some arbitrary
benchmarks that okay
we
have industrial benchmark of 70 accuracy
then i ask like okay
why 70 percent accuracy because
everybody uses 70 accuracy i mean that
was the answer that happens yeah
and um
also quite often uh what we observed
ourselves that uh
comparing metrics between uh different
subsets of data
i like this approach is used to
identify forecast problems yeah
and
but can we really use the same things
for
machine learning forecasting on a really
granular level with multiple intensive
factors let's let's discuss and look a
bit further
then let me introduce also our demand
forecasting use case so uh demand
forecasting uh use case that we are
mostly doing at uh blue yonder
for predicting demand for retail and
manufacturers um
has like a few
important features first of all demand
is a random variable
so doesn't matter how precise we can
predict demand for tomorrow anyway it
has some
statistical fluctuations
then demand is often discrete quantity
on countable atomic objects
would it be apples t-shirts
macbooks whatever
and underlying process are rather
independent
in time
and for example
one customer coming to the shop is
independent to another customer coming
from to the show and it can come on can
not to come that's why for example some
underlying assumptions as possible
distribution for demand
can make sense
demand can be
demanded sales for example for grocery
fashion and
typical granularity forecasting will be
product store date
also it could be
from a factory like demand as a order
then it could be consumer package goods
and
typical prediction granularity could be
that we predict for product location for
example distribution center or
manufacturing and for example week or
even months
and maybe customer channel who is
buying from the manufacturing
and
traditional of course evaluation process
is that we
train on something in sample
and we predict something for out of
sample obvious and then we compare our
metrics out of sample
a few more words that for traditional
forecasting um
with simple relatively simple algorithms
uh be like split entrances now then etc
while machine learning forecasting
can give us much more advanced forecasts
by uh using additional causals like
weather promotions prices like here on
the right example you can see effect of
promotions
and definitely uh if you would not
include promotions they can be learned
because then like
might be independent from seasonality of
or other time serious patterns
uh one more important thing that model
uh modern machine learning forecasting
quite often uh is uh probabilistic
forecasting
because it's quite
different things if i say that tomorrow
we will sell 15 apples
from tomorrow we'll sell 15 apples on
average and there is your probability
distribution that we say well for
example uh 22 apples with two percent
probability and so on and so on there
are number of benefits that we can
better control
of our uncertainty and we can do smarter
uh objective optimization i will tell a
few words on the next slide and for
uh
next number of the next examples we
would assume that demand
has a person distribution that is kind
of reasonable for
retail business maybe selling apples
t-shirts or whatever
then let me go further and
i think the last introduction slide is
that like
what actually
the main usage of such forecasting it
could be price optimization it could be
a stock fulfillment or storage stores
replenishment it could be promotion
planning
manufacturing planning a lot of stuff
and what are actually benefits of this
deterministic forecasts we predict 15 we
might be order 15 maybe with some safety
gap
who knows yes with probabilistic for
forecast we can do much clearer
optimization of some particular cost
function function or for example we can
minimize combination of wastes and
loss because of the
lost sales costs depending on our
target function
also limitations
for example we have only 10 in stock and
we predict 15 okay then we can correct
our predictions and go with final
prediction of 10 because we can sell
more than we have in stock
but in limitations when we talking about
probabilistic forecast we can just cut
away part of the probabilistic
distribution then we again have nice
probability distribution we can work on
and optimize on
so uh having all this in mind background
and our use case let's go directly and
find uh
and look at our first problem
about matrix selection
the main
idea of uh
evaluating focus is for when we're
talking talking about single valid uh
forecast
it's just we take prediction take
observation calculate metric for example
relative main error
done yeah
uh when we're talking about
probabilistic uh forecasting there can
be
two approaches either we take
the full probability distribution
compare with observed
distribution of our sales and we can
calculate different statistical
distances
uh between these two shape two shapes
and these two distributions
there are a few problems with this uh
because first of all if we do this we
can't really compare this deterministic
forecast
and
as well it's a bit hard to derive a
business follow from this and explain to
business people no statisticians people
actually what we did and why it makes
sense and
and so on and so on
um
alternative way is it is that we have
our prediction probability distribution
and then we
take some point estimator from this
predicted probability distribution for
example mean yeah
then we also have our observation and
then we calculate some particular metric
and then the other problems arises is
the different point estimator selection
can lead actually to drastically
different results one thing if i select
mean of my distribution other thing if i
select for example median
and actually a lot of metrics uh don't
make sense for some particular use cases
as it was discussed before like mapper
for something with zero
sales situations
and then we will go with this campaign
numbers approach for first examples
let me just
show you some
formulas
and have a look at two examples imagine
we have two examples one product that is
sold on average with uh nine point forty
forty seven sales per day and another
product uh that's sold 0.6
sales per day what will be probability
distribution under uh poisson assumption
you can see on this slide as well you
can see mean median and so-called minus
1 median that will explain further uh
for this particular distribution
and let's assume that we ideally
predicted this distribution and
everything fine yeah then the question
arise actually what will be the ultimate
number of our metric
and assuming that we ideally predicted
this distribution but it's just taking
this statistical nature
if we look at a mean square error
actually the
min square error is minimized by
mean of this distribution
and the mean of this distribution for
the left one is
9.47 and for the right one is
0.6
okay so we will take this mean
incorporate in a mean square error and
then we get the best mean square error
yeah uh if it talking about mean
absolute error actually it's minimized
by median
so it will be nine
sales for left and actually zero sales
for
right
case for closer in case
and if you're talking about a mapper
the smallest mapper is achieved with
minus one median it is median of
modified distribution as you can see
here and
actually
the numbers that we will minimize mapper
will be
eight for
relatively fast selling products and
one for relatively slow selling product
on the right example so you can see that
actually different point estimators
gave us really different values for
metrics and actually they optimize even
different metrics at the end so
it means that if you would have too
forecast
that you optimize i said to you like
create it in some in some way
it might be that
using some particular metric will be
will give you wrong result just because
you created your forecast
based on minimization one function and
then you compare another function
and what you can do you can select smart
point estimate estimator for this case
depending on the metric you want to
evaluate your model with
so yeah select metrics wisely and select
metrics that are relevant for your
business point estimator or vice versa
if you know that your focus will be
related on under some uh
metric you can find out the uh what is
what the point estimate is minimizing
this matrix and then
take this point estimator and uh from
your probabilistic forecast
now moving to a bit more
general problem is like apple to apple
comparison that actually not so
easy sometimes not actually so widely
understood
uh also called scaling problem
let me give you a number of toy examples
for example uh we have one product
with uh the following demand that either
this 50 probability it has zero sales
and 50 probabilities has one sale
and then per day it will sold either one
or the zero time uh
time so what will be the best demand
prediction it will be obviously 0.5 yeah
and 0.5 will lead to a remaining year of
100
for perfect forecast
then uh if we just aggregate it in time
just one bucket in two
we will get best demand prediction of
one and then we get rme f50
actually so formally we took the same
forecast we just did aggregation and we
got drastically different errors and if
you go and
say like we have 100 percent error or we
have 50 error or sometimes
customers has
or your boss or your organization has
some old forecasts on quite aggregated
level they calculate some metrics
then you bring some advanced granular
forecast and then they calculate the
same matrix and sometimes even
forgetting
aggregating the focus to
the corresponding time level or the
corresponding granularity
and then it can lead to the problems you
should understand this at the end
and
let's take another example for some high
selling products that i just sold 10
times or
20 times
so uh actually this bad forecast of 10
while the best forecast will be 15 sales
per day we'll get rme of 33 percent
that's actually
better than
previous examples so at the end if
you're evaluating on really really
different scales
uh different focus and you don't make
your scale consistent between different
forecasts or you can end up on this
pitfall of
scaling issues
yeah so um
what like kind of conclusions we can
derive from this first of all
we need to compare metrics for different
forecasts at the same aggregation level
we shouldn't compare
apple forecast for apples with focused
via for
boxes of apples
we should compare apples to apples
then
uh we should understand that uh when we
compare benchmarks we should uh
know where these benches come from from
what garden reality from whatever
so we shouldn't just accept that there
is some benchmark
uh for our focus quality and
when we're comparing different uh data
sub groups for example apple sales uh
apple vs dragon fruits
uh
we should understand that actually they
have different selling rate and they
have different statistical nature for
this product that's why like some
metrics that make sense for apple some
arrows that make sense for apple apples
will not make sense for dragon fruits
second problem is knowing your limits
so uh if your boss come to you and ask
you like okay i want tomorrow you to
provide forecast with 95 accuracy
and it's like what yeah why why why 95
crucify even can we reach it i mean what
you do do prototyping or whatever
so it's better to understand first
actually what the ultimate uh
error you can reach yeah
because uh your error has uh two
ingredients first of all it's a
reducible error that for example overall
focus bias that can can reduce and
irreducible error for example
statistical fluctuations or statistical
nature of your data
and if we take two previous examples
there
for the first example actually best
relative mean absolute error is 0.17
so 70 percent error that we cannot go
down further and
for second example
the best uh relative means of error will
be 24
so we really can't go down below this
error
and
again if
your boss asks you can you please reach
95 accuracy
um
then you can say okay we have average
sales of 9.47
and taking in the account statistical
nature actually we just
cannot reach this accuracy as we cannot
exceed speed of light it's just
statistical nature we can't reach it you
can't do better than for example 0.24
that's why like it's important before
evaluating forecasts to understand what
is the ultimate
performance you can reach based on some
reducible error for example based on
statistical flotations
and this actually it will highly really
depend on uh scale you're
working on
or your predicted demand scale
yep so because you will have different
statistical uncertainty based on your
predicted demand
so
what was wrong yeah then next problem i
would like to talk about is grouping
your data in the correct way
uh it is important to
uh
quite often it's appointed to every
relative model that you actually group
your model for example between slow
selling products and fast selling
products yeah
and now you both come to you and ask
like actually why your focus is so bad
for slow selling products and comparing
them with good products like products or
why some particular forecast
actually better for solution products
than yours focused
and then start thinking and okay
and that may be
our methodology is not fully correct
and
here you can see as an example
that uh
two example imagine you have demand with
uh
either
ninety percent probability to stay the
same and ten percent probability to
change and you have just two states zero
and one so either zero sale either one
sale
so good forecast for the first case will
be 0.9 and for the second case will be
0.1 but while bias forecast will be 0.85
and 0.05 and in the end
if you actually be in your final results
in observed demand
you will end up
having your actually blue so reasonable
focus
looking like
wars
then actually buys focus just because
you beamed with something some
information that you will get for this
feature information that you'll get
later and not know
and this could be a big big problem in
this case when you're re-leveling uh
forecast uh
for different subgroups of data and what
is
is called kind of constant bias and you
can uh go and look at this blog post
for more details and generally uh
here you can see on the left and right
mean predicted demand on the left with
bint observed demand for person
numerical experiment on the personal
assumption and you can see that it's
actually even for ideal forecast it will
lie far from a diagonal
so
the conclusion on this is that
better to do your demand splitting or
subgroup splitting based on information
available now it will maybe produce
groups it may be predicted rates
like being predicted demand but not on
some things that you will get in the
future like real observations based on
the future otherwise your judgment could
be biased based on this
and in addition actually binning demand
makes a different product really more
comparable and now coming to my
conclusion
let's
take everything together and try to
understand
actually how
we can avoid all these biases first of
all on the left we select some
meaningful metric for example for us it
would be a relative mean absolute error
secondary we knowing our limits so we
know that our limits we cannot exceed
and get smaller error that
under this red
curve
then we also be in or group by our
current available data for example being
predicted demand and as well actually
when we've been in predicted demand it
makes different product groups or
categories like apples and dragonflues
more comparable yeah and here you can
see a blue and green focus one for
prototype
one and two and yellow and red focus two
for prototype one and prototype two and
actually this picture is kind of amazing
because you can extract so much
information let me give you a few
examples you can already judge that
actually forecast
one is worse than forecast two because
your your metrics are much below for all
sailing rates
and even
you can see that
a lot of opportunities for improving
your focus with focus 2
uh you get from high selling products
with around sailing race of a thousand
or 200
second pro interesting observations that
for example for product type 1 and
product type 2 are not really comparable
you can see that product type 2 doesn't
have
high selling examples it's mostly only
within south slang region with small
demand
but
actually
it is much closer to ideal situation
and in this case if you would just
aggregate everything you will get worse
metric but from this you can just it's
much closer to a deal case and also you
can judge that focus 2 can't improve
this metric much you can't improve it
much because it's already close to ideal
close to its statistical limits
yeah
so
and
that's more or less eat what i wanted to
tell you and show this picture
so
well think about this think how you
evaluate your forecast understand your
limits
uh
do smart grouping and
let me know if you are interested in
some more information and yeah don't
hesitate join our web page and our blog
post we are posting more information
about and more details and more mass
behind all these problems that i uh
described today
yeah thank you
[Applause]
thank you a lot alia for the insights
today
let's go to
slido
so the first question you talk about
picking the right metric for different
scenarios assuming your customer doesn't
understand much isn't the answer always
mipa or mia
if the customer doesn't understand much
i mean if your customer doesn't as much
first you need to educate how try to
educate customers you shouldn't give up
on educating customers
so
second point is uh you should understand
what actually
is important business case for the
customer and try to select metric that
correspond to the business case of the
customer because usually metric is
illustration of
losses that customer will
experience under some assumptions for
example
it could be like slow sales or
whatever and different metrics are
actually
since they're minimizing different
numbers can be more appropriate for some
particular type of laws that it's
important for customer
so
i hope it answers
thank you
next one uh you mentioned you can
compare the predicted distribution and
the actual one
how do you get the actual distribution
since you just observed one same number
i mean we have quite long coverage
period for example uh i'm not uh talking
about that we absorb in exactly one but
we have sold sales over a long period of
time and we run evaluation on back test
on a long period of time and then we'll
already have some distribution of sales
at that of course on one number you can
do
much
statistical difference between different
uh distributions but if you collect
enough uh back test data then yeah you
can
cool demand stance demand tends to be
over dispersed
is poison distribution really better
than negative binomial distribution for
instance uh
negative binomial is definitely better
but it has two parameters so it's a bit
more complex but it's definitely uh
much more appropriate for this use case
i just use as possum assumptions as a
simple assumptions because it has only
one parameter
for discrete sales forecast
should we not first
discretize around the forecast before we
calculate the error
um
i think rounding should be on the part
of decision making how this forecast is
consumed at the end because what we
would like to provide we would like to
price the best focus is possible because
if we uh when we provide the full
distribution
at the end we provide this full tips
distribution and then this distribution
can be optimized and distribution
formula is collection of again rounded
numbers with their probabilities
at the end
it's always comes from how this focus
will be consumed and how this will be
focused used at the end in some further
optimization problem
process or ordering process
so we are running out of time one minute
so has to be a short answer this one
when predicting a distribution isn't the
mode or peak
of the distribution the best point
estimator
depends on the business case in the
metric
again as it was exactly the messaging
that different metrics or different
business cases could lead to different
point estimators of your distribution
as the most optimal point estimators
thank you uh so we have three left over
questions which you might uh direct
directly to the speaker uh as we are out
of time but please join me
in to thank you elia for the great
presentation
[Applause]